normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Obama
faces backlash for film's warning about
white people so uh Netflix puts out this
movie called uh what is it called uh
Leave the World Behind where a Cyber
attack basically destroys modern
civilization and there's this line where
uh let me see see if we can pull it up
here quote I am asking you to remember
that if the World falls apart Trust
should not be doled out so easily to
anyone especially white people and
that's the message but I guess Luke you
uh you watch some of this or I saw half
of the movie yesterday and uh
automatically I don't know if we want to
get into some of the spoiler alert but
it plays off of the similar kind of
character types that you always see on
Netflix that you always see in the TV
commercials and TV shows now the the the
the white guy was a loser the white
woman was just a racist hateful
individual where literally the movie
started with her saying how she hates
everybody and the white guy was a cuck
or something yeah he's like a he's like
a beta totally scared pathetic and
running and crying and I'm like oh yeah
yeah you know just the average kind of
bull crap that you usually see in enter
entertainment now which literally just
plays on your subconscious and uh tries
to install messages in there that are uh
dehum and divisive especially racially
uh so I watched half of the movie there
was also a very interesting scene
surrounding Teslas so um I still haven't
watched all of it um I don't like it cuz
I already see a lot of the kind of
subliminal messaging in there that's
like okay this is pandering to the woke
ESG score message that comes from a lot
of these and you know what my attitude
is for most of this stuff is well okay I
guess because I'll tell you something if
you listen
to shows like this you will be better
off in the event of a crisis or
emergency if you listen to wokeness yeah
you're not going to last very long the
world of the woke is entirely dependent
on the people the working class the
labor and those who actually make the
system function this is a movie about a
Cyber attack which shuts down the grid
if you were to follow the mentality of
these people you would not last very
long so what we're seeing now is with
movies like this you better not trust
white people oh so in the event of a
collapse or crisis they want everyone
fighting each other that's not going to
help you Unity will help you survive
coming together and working together
helps you survive I look at these states
where they just had that story out of
Texas that woman had the Supreme Court
barred her from getting an abortion and
what had happened was she said uh I
forgot what the the the condition is the
baby had something like what's it called
TR trcy or something do you guys know
what it was tricomi 18 right it's it's
an additional chromosome I think they
said that the baby would likely die it
wouldn't live very long and so she
sought an abortion and a lower court
granted it but the Supreme Court said no
because the doctor was seeking
pre-authorization
without justifying anyone's life
actually being in danger Supreme Court
of Texas stops it she fle the state I
believe she had already fled the state
when it was going to the Supreme Court
and got the abortion anyway when you
look at this what do you think the
world's going to look like in 20 30 40
50 years with the people who follow the
Obama vision of woke wokeness hating
each other based on race and aborting
their kids I don't think there's going
to be very many successful people on the
left no they're going to be struggling
to eat they're not they don't even know
where food comes from as it is if there
really was World War III you know you
got Jack bobic and Alex Jones talking
about a false flag starting fullscale
war with Russia right right before the
election in October the only way Joe
Biden could possibly win and what do you
think's going to happen when there's
rationing when there's crisis yo I put
up this video it's from a clown world
and it's a guy holding fruit loaf and a
piece of KFC and he says what do
chickens like better the chicken
immediately runs up and start starts
eating the chicken leg and everyone's
like wow that's so messed up that's
funny cuz anybody who has chickens is
like and chickens eat each other like
relatively often like they'll like not
like super often but if one dies they'll
just eat the body eat they're cannibals
yeah they're carnivores right they're
just going to eat it and uh we actually
had a chicken dye it got its uh uh uh
the the smok the whatever protecting it
from the boys cuz the girls get their
backs torn up when the when the boys are
going for their business and it went
over her face you couldn't see so they
just aler to death and I'm like chicken
are brutal man my point is you know the
average person has no idea how to do
even the most basic things to survive
and they're they're watching this media
what what's what's scaring me is we're
creating this closed loop basically you
have this this trajectory from the dawn
of civilization until today where there
have been successful ideas technology
methodologies social Concepts morality
that has led to tremendous success this
branch has happened it's it's it's
branched off and and then instead of
leading themselves to a brighter future
developing new techniques developing
survival they just loop around in a
circle so now they're all just trapped
in one big circle of failure and should
the system collapse they'll just spiral
out and instead of trying to get people
to work together to to be in in an
environment where they kind of are able
to trust each other and to be open with
each other they're there they're just
getting the message over and over and
over again don't trust white people
white people are bad all your problems
are because of white people that
messaging is everywhere it's subliminal
it's overt and it's getting to a point
where every form of media it's it's it's
unavoidable and and it and it's done in
such an egregious way where where you
kind of got to wonder what's the end
point here where is this going to go
especially when we're going to have more
economic hardships that's guaranteed
there's going to be some kind of larger
problem before the election that's
guaranteed there's going to be something
major happening during those events
people are going to have to come
together work with each other
communicate with each other but with
this larger divisive nature ever since
Occupy Wall Street ever since the
corporate media became obsessed with
race and Division in this country that's
not going to be likely there's going to
be packs there's going to be gangs
there's going to be alliances there's
going to be people uh dealing with the
situation just like we see kind of
unfold in the prison system where we
have ethnic groups and organizations
aligning themselves together attacking
each other just because they're
different that's the type of society
that they want for you that's very
honorable uh for you to say Luke because
you know as a person of color you
looking out for the white man is is very
honorable damn right what's so odd about
this um is that there are few people
more influential and Powerful in the
world than the Obamas um their reaches
is as as large as the King right I mean
there are very few people who have that
much power um and also for for good or
for ill mostly for ill um or falsehood
uh internationally beloved right like
they they still have this aura that they
are these wonderful people Etc why would
why would this be the movie they would
want to make right when you think of his
speech of 2004 at the convention when
you think of the you realize what a big
phony Barack Obama is I've always known
he to be a favorite he was a consultant
on the film but still why would he be a
consultant on this film why would he say
like why can't we make a film that that
just shows the goodness of human nature
that shows the goodness of America if
there is some sort of a c of society
you're allowed to make a
post-apocalyptic film but why can't we
make one that shows communities working
get look at Independence Day that's
post-apocalyptic yeah you know why why
is this the type of film that he's
lending his name to and that's that
shows you who these people I've I've
always disliked the Obamas I've always
seen them for the phonies they are um
and I think we're still dealing with a
lot of the consequences of what they
inflicted on our country phon too too
light um yeah I'm trying to evil um well
but I'm in I'm in the the the you know
open access at at at 10:30 I'll be a
little bit more at 10:00 I'll be a
little bit no mevolent malevolent evil
is a is a good way to put it oh yeah I
have some dude jokes I want to make I'm
going to save for also the after show
and shouts out to my friend Larry
Sinclair uh we'll get into that later as
it say this is your platform you could
do anything Mr President why is this
what you're choosing to do and represent
and push and promote on everyone
especially as of course this movie came
out right after the new of a Chinese
Cyber attack with Chinese Affiliated
organizations what better way to release
a movie and get everyone watching it
than talk about the main issue that all
the news organizations are talking about
at the same time as of course there
probably is a lot of seeding of
narratives and to have this Narrative of
something like a cyber polygon that the
world economic Forum was recently
Drilling and doing war games with Russia
for there there is something to kind of
note here when it comes to a lot of
people being like Oh you know there was
also a lot of different pandemic movies
released in right before 2020 uh why did
that happen again some people say
predictive programming some people say
coincidence who knows um we we can
speculate all long what's predictive
programming what is that so it it comes
to there's many different kind of facets
and understanding of it but when it
comes to things I I got to be careful
what I say here because the examples I
have of it is with what happened in New
York City 200 is is predictive
programming like the powers that be will
in Ally make propaganda signaling
something coming or the human
consciousness is moving in a certain
direction and then along with that
something happens in in in the real
world I think both could be true uh and
especially when we look at the
intelligence agencies and their planting
of new stories and suppression of other
news stories they are essentially uh
planting the N another example that I
would give outside of the one in 2001 in
New York City is the the specific
buildup to the war in Iraq that war in
Iraq was sold to us for a very long time
before it actually started there was a
lot of uh seeds that were planted there
was a lot of predictive programming when
it came to entertainment when it came to
Hollywood when it came to programs like
24 that were trying to normalize the
concepts and ideas of torture of
rendition of taking Americans and
actually taking them to Black sites in
foreign countries and torturing them for
the betterment of this country and that
kind of entertainment did play a role in
our current political discourse where
the government was saying yeah we could
torture people and some of the American
people that were watching this TV
programming were kind of acquest to
saying yeah of course he's they're going
to save us from being nuked like we saw
in that movie or in that TV series
that's a form of predictive programming
that also I would say on the hippie
dippy level does play on the collective
Consciousness but more on a direct level
when it comes to CIA and intelligence
agencies being major producers and
hiring major producers and and actors to
plant a lot of these ideas that then go
along with the larger scops that they
have uh available for everyone thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net